what's up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and mcu i'm your host warren
thompson and it looks like things are
getting pretty crazy for doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness we have
some crazy rumors to talk about today
plus a report that tom cruise is going
to be entering the mcu at some point in
time a lot of people thought we saw
superior iron man in the trailer for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness but i think most people have
realized by now at this point that this
is actually going to be a maria rambo
variant of captain marvel however that
does not mean that a tony stark variant
isn't going to be in multiverse of
madness after all we do have the ultron
bots and those were most likely created
by tony stark but we also do have a very
very interesting rumor about the scene
with the illuminati and when they start
fighting the scarlet witch and doctor
strange as it turns out this scene may
not be what exactly you think it is and
hopefully it's true because if it's true
professor xavier might not die a lot of
people probably will going up against
the scarlet witch but hopefully we don't
have to see professor x die once again
on screen so let's break down what you
need to know and of course if you're new
be sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos so there
has been a ton of talk about tom cruise
joining the mcu for a very long time now
ever since it was kind of announced that
variants are going to play a pretty
decent part in doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness then reports
started to go around about the
illuminati possibly being in multiverse
of madness and then new rumors came
about that tom cruise might be playing
iron man as a part of the illuminati
then we got the official trailer for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness and the illuminati was
officially revealed and then we thought
we saw superior iron man but taking a
look at some other tv spots that have
come out now it does seem to be that
this person right here who we all
thought was superior iron man is indeed
the maria rambo variant of captain
marvel sadly not tony stark and again
there is just so much room for tony
stark to appear in multiverse of madness
that it is a possibility and today we
have a report that states that tom
cruise is probably entering the mcu at
some point not necessarily in multiverse
of madness but entering the mcu at some
point which is something that we've been
hearing for a while this report comes
with other news about doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness all coming
from grace randolph now i know some
people question grace but she does have
reliable sources in fact she tweeted on
january 14th that doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness is going to be
approximately two hours long without the
credits and recently it was announced
that yes doctor strange 2 is going to be
right at the 2 hour mark but it is worth
noting that in this tweet she also said
that tom cruise is not in the movie and
some other surprise cameo got cut as
well but a couple of days ago she
replied to her own tweet stating as i
said before tom cruise might have been
held back i'm 99 sure he's coming to the
mcu she even pointed out the fact that
yes while he's been filming mission
impossible this whole entire time he did
take a mysterious break to go to atlanta
a few months ago most likely to film
something at marvel studios in atlanta
now there have been a lot of supposed
leaks of tom cruise filming things for
marvel studios we don't know what is
real and what is fake if any of it is
real but considering the fact that
marvel studios wanted tom cruise to be
really the first character of the marvel
cinematic universe iron man it would
make sense that they would still want
him in the mcu and want him to play
maybe a variant of tony stark or a new
character entirely marvel studios wanted
him to play tony stark unfortunately but
also fortunately it didn't work out and
robert downey jr became the perfect iron
man however in a movie where variants
are going to be a big part of the film
it would make perfect sense for tom to
appear as a variant of iron man because
in our multiverse there exists a
universe where tom cruise actually did
get the role of iron man and he was the
main iron man of the mcu so it would be
really cool to see him cameo now
professor xavier is confirmed to be a
part of the illuminati we've heard his
voice in the trailer we know it's him
plus patrick stewart already came out
and said yep that's me so we know he's
going to be in the film but a lot of
people are worried that we're gonna have
to watch him die yet again on screen
some reports came out way before we even
got the first teaser trailer for this
film stating that wanda was actually
going to fight the illuminati and many
people if not all would die and rumors
of a scene started to go around of
professor x trying to stop wanda much
like he tried to stop jean grey in x-men
the last stand unfortunately the rumored
outcome of that battle was wanda killing
professor x now a ton has happened to
this movie since they shot the original
cut it has definitely been changed and
these rumors go back so far that they
might not even be on the table anymore
however we do know that wanda slash the
scarlet witch is indeed going to fight
the illuminati however this scene might
not play out the way we think it will is
she going to kill some members of the
illuminati and possibly some other
variants in other different universes oh
yeah i'm definitely thinking that the
kill count is going to be pretty high
for wanda she's a mother trying to save
her kids plus she's probably going to be
a little bit possessed by the dark hold
and maybe c'thun is behind it as well
combine that with her being the most
powerful being in the universe and
probably multiverse yeah she's gonna be
killing some people plus this film is
also kind of supposed to be a horror
film so there's that as well so in the
trailer we see wanda fighting captain
marvel maria rambo variant of her and
the surroundings getting pretty
shattered and we know that this is
indeed the illuminati's headquarters
because in the trailer when the ultron
bots are going through the courtyard
taking doctor strange to meet the
illuminati we see certain statues that
we also see in the scene where wanda is
fighting captain marvel so it's very
clear she's going to fight the
illuminati and probably kill most of
them but here's where a certain twist
might come into play there's a rumor
going around that professor x is indeed
going to try and stop her but not in a
way that you think the rumor is that
professor x is going to fight wanda but
he's going to fight her in her mind now
professor x is one of the most powerful
psychic mutants out there and on top of
that he is more in control of his powers
than most mutants are and this is
definitely something i can see him doing
because it makes sense professor x is in
a wheelchair he is not nearly as mobile
as wanda is so the best bet for him is
to indeed fight her in her mind to make
her believe that she is actually
fighting him but in reality it's really
professor x trying to take over her mind
to calm her down and stop her now i'm
almost 100 sure that this is going to be
unsuccessful and that wanda is going to
realize what is happening defeat him and
then in real life there's gonna be some
trouble for professor xavier but will he
kill her here or will he take this
opportunity while he's fighting inside
of her mind to physically leave so he
doesn't get killed i actually hope this
happens i know some people might not
want this to happen because they want
the fight to be real but i know the
fight between her and the other members
of the illuminati and other variants as
well are going to be 100 real so we'll
get plenty of action on that front i
just don't want to see professor x die
again but heck maybe we'll see tom
cruise's iron man die in the scene as
well now i am starting to doubt that tom
cruise is going to be in multiverse
abandons because a few different
insiders at this point have said they
don't think tom cruise is in the movie
now you never really know what's going
to happen in a movie like this but i
would keep expectations for tom cruise's
iron man pretty low there may be a
different iron man in the film again it
makes sense considering the ultron bots
but it might not be tom cruise's iron
man however it does look like tom cruise
is at one point going to be joining the
mcu whether that's as a variant of tony
stark or perhaps a new character it is
clear that the multiverse is going to be
a huge part of the mcu moving forward
and will definitely be exploring it in
other projects such as loki season 2
perhaps ant-man and the wasp quantomania
where they introduced kang but would you
want tom cruise to play a tony stark
variant or would you like him to play a
completely different and new character
in the mcu let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
marvel news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
[Music]